Geneviève Guilbaud ministre des
Transports et de la mobilité durable du
Québec bonsoir madame Guilbaud bonsoir
monsieur Roy ce qui frappait ce matin
bon au-delà de tout ça donc on va se
parler c'est que vous étiez totalement
seul pour affronter tout ça on est
habitué à des conférences de presse avec
beaucoup de ministres le Premier
ministre les mers vous étiez seul en
disant mais excusez-nous ça marchera
plus cette affaire
ouais ben l'an dernier la dernière
annonce qu'on avait faite sur le réseau
express de la capitale parce que le
grand projet qu'on a dans les deux
régions c'est le réseau express de la
capitale et le troisième lien est une
des cartes composantes et la dernière
annonce qu'on avait faite pour passer du
monotube qui était le premier gros tube
des mesures tout ça on avait annoncé
l'an dernier un bitume à 6.5 milliards
et j'étais à l'époque ministre la
capitale nationale et c'était seulement
le ministre des Transports et moi qui
avions fait l'annonce donc c'est pas
c'est pas inhabituel qu'on fasse des
annonces par nous-mêmes comme ministre
ou à deux ministres et mais surtout
aujourd'hui c'est comme ça que j'ai
commencé ce matin c'était une journée
difficile c'est une journée difficile
c'est une décision très difficile que je
suis à l'annoncer c'est un changement
dans le projet de troisième lien on
continue d'avoir un troisième lien mais
c'est pas celui auquel les gens
s'attendaient alors c'est très difficile
pour nous les élus parce que je sais que
c'est difficile pour nos citoyens qu'on
représente qui nous ont élu qui ont ces
attentes là et dont certains sont déçus
en ce moment sont probablement en colère
aussi pour certains et ça vaut aussi
pour mes 15 collègues on est 16 élus
dans la capitale nationale et dans
chaudière à palaches donc pour mes 15
collègues c'est très très difficile
certains en particulier alors c'est une
journée je pense pour faire oui cette
annonce là parce qu'on attendait les
fameuses études à jour les données à
jour depuis des mois je m'étais engagé à
les partager dès que je les recevrai et
donc aujourd'hui je l'ai fait mais je
l'ai fait dans la sobriété et dans la
plus grande transparence sur notre notre
état d'esprit et notre état émotionnel
de devoir prendre cette décision là vous
parlez madame Guilbaud de colère ce qui
choque beaucoup beaucoup de gens c'est
que vous étiez tellement sûr de votre
coup à la CAQ au Gouvernement sur ce
projet là vous disiez on posait des
questions monsieur Legault tout au long
de la campagne on disait mais vous
n'avez pas encore les études monsieur le
goût à ce qu'on devrait peut-être être
prudent avant de dire que ça va se faire
coûte que coûte il disait c'est évident
que ça va se faire les besoins sont
évidents et pendant deux campagnes
électorales vous avez dit ça aux gens et
là vous arrivez aujourd'hui vous nous
dites savez-vous le projet est inutile
c'est ça qui est dur à aller
il est pas inutile je dirais pas le
projet
inutile parce que le projet de 3e lien
va se faire mais dans une autre forme au
départ on avait annoncé au départ mais
l'an dernier un bitume et là il y avait
deux tubes dans lesquels on avait à la
fois des voitures et du transport
collectif parce que c'est important
d'avoir du transport collectif mais on
mélangeait les deux dans chacun des deux
tubes donc ça nous limitait pas mal
avoir des autobus parce que tu vas avoir
des voitures puis du transport collectif
dans le même tube ça te prend des
autobus qui roulent sur les mêmes voies
mais en ce moment le et là donc on a les
fameuses données à jour là que j'ai
présenté ce matin qui en passant sont
toutes disponibles maintenant sur le
site internet dans une salle mais vous
l'avez du transport collectif et toutes
les possibilités qui s'offrent à nous en
ayant seulement du transport collectif
dans le tunnel c'est-à-dire on peut
faire plus et mieux peut-être que des
autobus mais on va l'évaluer vous avez
dit ce matin madame la ministre les
besoins ne sont pas là les besoins ne
sont pas là bon je parle des voitures je
parle pas du transport en commun donc
quand je dis inutile c'est pareil
vous dites ce projet-là qu'on a tant
vendu au Québec est devenu
inutile parce que les données qu'on a
puis je vais vous montrer juste un petit
tableau là puis ça va donner une idée
aux gens c'est que oui il y a une baisse
d'achalandage sur les ponts on voit le
Pont Pierre la porte en 2022 il y en a
moins qu'en 2019 autrement dit on n'est
pas revenu à la période pré pandémie
mais comment vous pouvez avec une année
où il y a moins de voitures décidé qu'un
projet ne fonctionne pas pour les 75
prochaines années
puisque vous montrez c'est le tableau de
la chalandage sur les ponts mais il y a
bien d'autres tableaux aussi puis il y a
un
certain nombre de considérations dans
cette décision là c'est sûr que tu sais
c'est pas seulement un élément il y a
aussi la manière dont les gens vivent et
se déplacent maintenant parce que la
pandémie est terminée mais ça a laissé
des traces dans notre vie et c'est pas
vrai qu'on vit de la même manière qu'en
2019 même si on n'est plus en pandémie
les gens télétravail beaucoup se
déplacent autrement quand on télétravail
c'est des fois on va à même notre
journée aller faire nos commissions
faire certaines choses alors les
déplacements ne sont plus les mêmes
beaucoup de télétravail et lundi les
vendredis et les heures de pointe aussi
les heures de pointe sont demeurer les
mêmes de 6 à 9 de 15 à 18 mais il y a
moins de gens aux heures de pointe sur
les ponts donc une répartition
différente de la chaleur d'âge des coûts
aussi très élevés on évaluait le projet
en dernier on avait parlé de 6.5
milliards et là avec toute le contexte
tout le contexte de la construction la
surchauffe c'est compliqué les
dépassements de coups dans les projets
on était à 9.5 10 milliards et donc
la fin de facteurs qui ont été pris en
considération qui font qu'en ce moment
effectivement on ne juge pas qu'il y ait
un besoin mais c'est évolutif un jour
c'est sûr qu'il va falloir faire quelque
chose là les on voit le pompier à la
porte c'est vrai qu'il y aura pas
éternellement mais il est bon encore
quelques décennies avec tous les travaux
d'inspection et d'entretien qu'on fait
donc en ce moment il y en a pas besoin
selon ses données là en ce moment il y a
pas de besoin vous dites mais on a les
données récentes pas supp pandémies pour
une seule année je vous repose la
question vous étiez tellement sûr de
vous laisser le gouvernement là vous
étiez tellement sûr de votre coup vous
avez fait deux campagnes électorales
là-dessus comment se fait-il que des
données post pandémies sur à peine une
année peut venir dérailler cette
certitude alors madame Guilbaud je vous
soumets que les experts beaucoup de gens
vous disaient on n'a pas besoin de cette
histoire là ça a été trop cher mais vous
disiez non non on en a besoin c'est ça
qu'on a de la misère à réconcilier
aujourd'hui
ouais mais c'est vrai qu'avant comme je
vous dis c'est une combinaison de choses
c'est pas seulement le nombre de
voitures qui passent sur le pont c'est
la répartition de cet achalandage là les
nouvelles habitudes de vie de
télétravail est-ce que dans 50 ans on va
encore télétravailler est-ce qu'on va
avoir tous recommencer à les travailler
en même temps du lundi au vendredi de
8h30 à 4h30 peut-être peut-être que ça
reviendra jamais il y a aussi le fait
qu'à Québec on a une économie très axée
on a beaucoup de gens de la fonction
publique ici la fonction publique
fédérale provinciale en télétravail
beaucoup une économie de service la
numérisation aussi de certains secteurs
a fait en sorte qu'on a moins des fois
de ressources humaines de gens qui se
promènent pour aller travailler donc
c'est une combinaison plusieurs facteurs
le financement aussi je vous parlais du
coup pour les projets de transport
collectif le fédéral on peut s'attendre
à une contribution de 40% alors pour la
partie routière il y avait une fermeture
de la part du fédérale donc ça faisait
certainement t'élever pardonnez-moi mais
on savait ça il y a quelques mois que le
fédéral ne finançait que les
infrastructures avec du transport en
commun
oui oui tout à fait c'est pour ça que je
dis que c'est pas un facteur isolé mais
le plus important je vous dirais c'est
les temps de parcours tous les temps de
parcours ont diminué et pendant ce
temps-là les parcours en voiture je vous
parle et en transport collectif c'est
extrêmement long c'est pas du tout
incitatif alors en mettant un tunnel de
transport collectif on diminue autant de
71 %. alors que pour leur routier de 37
%. là encore c'est des chiffres qui
parlent beaucoup vos collègues de la
région de chaudière à palage de Québec
sont dans leur souliers on a vu monsieur
drinville au bord des larmes Geneviève
Martin Biron
s'excuser on l'a promis on l'avait
fermement promis est-ce que la morale
Geneviève Guilbaud pour tout
gouvernement mais le vôtre en
particulier c'est d'avant de promettre
quelque chose faut peut-être avoir deux
trois études avoir une fondation
factuelle qui va faire qu'on va avoir un
plaidoyer qu'on va pas dire aux gens
c'est pas n'importe quoi qu'on promène
la réalité a changé monsieur j'ai pas le
choix de réinvoquer ça parce que c'est
ça la réalité ça me fait penser des fois
mon collègue de la santé qui se fait
questionner aussi pourquoi on a des
problèmes pourquoi la main d'oeuvre le
réseau de la santé et tout ça les listes
d'attente il y a eu une pandémie de deux
trois ans qui a eu tellement d'impact
dans la société que personne n'avait
prédite qu'on est arrivé en 2018 on
avait déjà fait campagne sur le
troisième lien donc on dit on va de
l'avant 2019 et début 2020 et mars 2020
gagne la pandémie et là on a vécu ça
jusqu'en 2022 et ensuite de son on est
encore en train de subir certains des
contrecoups de cette pandémie là même sa
proprement parler on a plus beaucoup de
masques et puis bon on recommence à
vivre à voir les gens qui sont les plus
confinés
le tunnel allait être là d'abord il y a
même pas être près de même matin puis à
l'être là pour 75 ans minimum donc oui
il y a une petite baisse il y aura une
remontée dans les courbes la courbe le
monde d'ailleurs la montrer tout à
l'heure mais en terminant vous dites
quoi aux électeurs de la région de
Québec qui ont voté pour vous en se
disant eux ils vont aller au bout de ce
projet là
premièrement je leur dis que pour ceux
qui sont déçus ou en colère aujourd'hui
je les comprends et c'est correct et moi
je m'attends je suis une élite moelle
moi et mes 15 collègues on s'attend en
fin de semaine souvent on fait
l'épicerie la fin de semaine on se
promène chacun chez nous et je m'attends
à ce qu'on reçoive des commentaires les
gens vont appeler dans nos bureaux de
circonscription et c'est correct
sentez-vous très à l'aise de le faire
puis moi et mes collègues aussi qui ont
manifesté certaines émotions et tout ça
c'est tout à fait correct qu'on vive ce
qu'on arrive maintenant on demeure
convaincu qui est pertinent pour deux
régions comme les nôtres d'avoir des
investissements mobilité de devenir la
grande zone économique influente
métropolitaine qu'on veut faire avec nos
deux régions d'intégrer nos
développements nos économies en ayant un
lien centre-ville à centre-ville et avec
du transport collectif moderne et
efficace pas des autobus comme ce qu'on
a toujours eu le qui attire pas les gens
parce que c'est trop long du transport
collectif moderne qui va libérer de la
place sur les ponts pour jouer là on
sait pas quand comment combien
mais même si on avait parlé du bitume
quand on parlait du bitume vous l'avez
dit tout à l'heure c'était pas construit
dans l'année courante ça prend un
certain nombre de temps ça va être la
même chose pour ce projet-là mais à
terme ça va être un beau projet qui va
être attrayant qui va nous permettre de
rivaliser avec les autres grandes villes
et qui va libérer de la place sur les
ponts actuels alors son aura un
troisième lien mais pas celui qu'on
avait promis
on verra on verra la suite des choses
Geneviève beau ministre des Transports
merci d'être venu nous voir en direct
merci au revoir